[Music]
ha no youtube just Louis in my friends
this is guns in here
welcome to the 26th episode of my chest
strap series in this episode I'm going
to show you a wonderful trap exists in
the Italian game from the white
perspective the opening arises after the
following model E 4 E Phi Knight to f3
Knight to c6 Bishop to c4 and the
trademark Italian move Bishop to c5 ok
white continues with d3 and black
responds with Knight to f6 so quickly
want to castle on the kingside and the
main line here runs with the move c3
however our trap e line start with
Knight to c3
now as black hasn't castle on the King
side it is perfectly fine for black to
play the moon d6 and liberate his other
Bishop as the obvious spin Bishop to g5
here doesn't walk because of the move at
6 and if Bishop drawbacks to the h4 then
G fire is a very strong reply and black
get a lot of space on the Kings side so
after the move at 6 white is more or
less obliged to capture elapsed X and
after Queen captures f6 the important of
Knight to c3 can be revealed because now
white can play Knight to d5
attacking to sports and that's why black
has the only moon in this position Queen
goes back to be R square afterwards
white will continue with this tricky
move c3 the good thing I like about this
trap is after the move d6 by force white
can reach to this position and here
black can already go wrong if he doesn't
play the careful moon in this lecture we
are going to concentrate on one of the
most popular choice by black namely
Bishop to e6 and if you check this
position in online database you will
find out that
there are more than 50 feed a games
played from this position including some
very high ranked players Bishop to e6 is
a very Nishal move as it pinned on the
knight and black is trying to finish his
development but amazingly enough it
turns out that this move is a big-time
disaster for the black and in all lines
white get a completely winning position
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out a winning move
which gives white a completely upper
hand did you find it
let's see surprisingly enough more games
continue with b4 which I think it's a
great deal of inaccuracy after that
Black has some surviving chances but the
killer MUOS
ahahaha so the spawn roller already
hitting the bishop and black is forced
to capture on d4
for example if black continues with
Bishop to b6 then the game can be
already decided as after Knight captures
b6 a captures b6 and the MU defy white
win the piece on the spot you might
think hang on but what about Knight to
e5 counter attacking the bishop well why
don't need to panic as he can calmly
play Bishop to d3 after black Bishop
moves anywhere let's say Bishop to d7
then before in fact trap the Black
Knight so it is very obvious that here
black has to capture on d4 and after
this White will recapture with the C
pawn attacking the bishop one more time
if Bishop to b6 then the same team
appear and black loses the piece so
again by force black has to play Bishop
to b4 check
which at first sight looks like a saving
resource but nope it's not working
because of the simple move Knight
captures before so white is a whole
piece of and at this Junction he has
given black which piece he wants to
capture the false capture Knight
captures before is obviously very bad
the simple reason is after Queen to e4
check we are hitting the night and if
Knight goes back to c6
then after defy white grab the piece and
in fact the game probably the most
critical response here is Bishop capture
c4 which at first sight solves all black
problems but still it's an illusion as
white still get a decisive advantage
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find a continuation where
white get an advantageous position okay
I hope you find this model Knight
captures e6 pawn captures c6 and now the
star move Queen to c2 attacking the
bishop and Beyond on c6 and
unfortunately for black
he cannot bury both of the threats there
are three choices black and mid over
here if Bishop to b5 which is a blunder
move the simple repetition is after the
move a for that Bishop doesn't have any
square to go has after Bishop to a6 and
queen capture c6 why clearly obtain a
piece so that's not a good choice for
the black well what about defy well the
same story we are going to hit the
bishop and if the bishop moves back then
we have a four and the c6 pawn drops
so accordingly black has to do a counter
attack with pawn captures ephone hitting
the night and I got this position
against a 1988 opponent where I clearly
get a superior age after Quinn captures
a full check black has the only move
Bishop to e6
after that I grab more pawns with Quinn
capture c6 check Bishop to d7 and Quinn
to c5 after the whole sequence not only
white has stopped black to castle on the
Kings side but at this point he is a
healthy pawn up last but not least what
happens if Bishop goes to the e6 well
you already guessed it yep you can
capture on c6 and after Bishop to d7 and
Queen to c3 not only white as a center
but he emerged with a clear point
advantage and with some accurate play
this is more than sufficient to create a
full point that's it guys I hope you
enjoy and learn this amazing trap in the
Italian game remember if your opponent
continues with Bishop to e6 then don't
play the move before but play this
winning move d4 and no matter however
black has spawned he get losing position
at the opening stage thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment on this and I'll
meet you in my next episode very soon
bye and take care